madame la ministre ma question porte sur
les problèmes de sécurité soulevés par
la diffusion de prise de vue aérienne
des prisons françaises sur google maps
ou google earth
je rappelle que l'arrêté du 27 octobre
2010 est fixe la liste des zones
interdites à la prise de vue aérienne
pour appareils photographiques ou
cinématographiques ou tout autre capteur
et qui liste les 247 zone interdite de
prises de vue aériennes en france parmi
lesquels figurent 68 prison des prises
de vues aériennes de l'un de ces sites
est ainsi passible d'un an
d'emprisonnement et de 75 euros d'amande
toutefois près d'un an après la
publication dudit arrêté une
cinquantaine de prisons demeurerait
visibles dont certaines accueillant des
individus dangereux
c'était il ya encore un mois le cas de
la maison centrale de réaux que
maintenant malheureusement tout le monde
connaît il y à un mois google expliqué
que cette absence de floutage par le
caractère non rétroactif de l'arrêté du
27 octobre 2010 est que ce dernier donc
ne s'appliquerait qu'aux photos prises
depuis 2017
or chacun sait que l'accès à ces prises
de vue aériennes dit ce ainsi le poste
de véritables problèmes de sécurité et
qu'il peut par exemple être utilisé pour
préparer et organiser des évasions
je rappelle aussi que constatant que ses
demandes de floutage de sites sensibles
sur google maps demeuré lettre morte
le ministère de la défense belge a
annoncé en octobre dernier sa volonté
d'attaquer google en justice
madame la ministre le 16 octobre dernier
google vous a annoncé par voie postale
le démarrage du floutage des vues
aériennes de prisons françaises de
visible google maps ou google earth
sans pour autant spécifier ses prisons
concernés dans le même temps google
s'engageait à vous tenir informé de
l'évolution du processus toutes les
trois semaines
aussi madame la ministre pourriez vous
me préciser le programme de déploiement
de ces floutage
où en sommes-nous donc est le cas c'est
chiant quelles mesures envisagées vous
afin de vous assurer que google respecte
effectivement le retrait ou le floutage
des urines de nos prisons afin de
garantir la sécurité de nos prisons
françaises la parole est à madame nicole
belloubet garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice
merci madame la présidente mais
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs aux
sénateurs bonhomme le 31 juillet dernier
j'ai effectivement transmis un courrier
à la direction de google france en lui
demandant de prendre les dispositions
techniques nécessaires pour garantir le
retrait ou le floutage des vues
aériennes sur google earth et google
maps des établissements pénitentiaires
listés en annexe des arrêtés pris les 27
janvier et 27 octobre 2017
la direction de google france m'a
répondu par deux courriers
le premier le 1er août pardon le premier
du 14 août et le second du 8 octobre
vous y avait fait allusion
google france m'a signalé que tout était
mis en oeuvre pour finaliser le floutage
de l'ensemble des lieux visés par les
arrêtés pris en 2017
d'ici le début du mois de décembre 2018
nous pourrons donc très prochainement
mesurer la portée de l'engagement qui a
été pris par google france mais je sais
que d'ores et déjà cela commence à être
effectif en partent en parallèle le
secrétariat général de la défense et de
la sécurité nationale conduit
actuellement des travaux qui rassemble
les experts juridiques des ministères
direction générale et agences concernées
pour adapter les dispositions juridiques
encadrant la prise de vue aérienne et
par satellite des sites sensibles
ce groupe de travail auquel participe le
ministère de la justice a pour objectif
de refondre le cadre juridique de la
captation d'image et de leur diffusion
afin de préserver les zones sensibles
considérés comme des points d'importance
vitale et stratégique
il vise l'ensemble des fournisseurs bien
au-delà donc des seuls services qui sont
proposés par google
ces travaux sont menés sur la base des
propositions émises par la direction de
la protection des installations moyens
et activités de la défense du ministère
des armées dans le rapport du 4 juin
2018 qu'elle a consacré à ce sujet
sans attendre le ministère de la justice
par arrêté du 12 octobre dernier 12
octobre 2018 a enrichi la liste des
zones interdites à la prise de vue
aérienne pour couvrir tous les
établissements les plus sensibles
portant le total de 38 à 89 sites
les travaux de recensement des
coordonnées gps des autres sites se
poursuivent afin que l'ensemble des
établissements pénitentiaires soient
prises en compte en 2019
comme vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur
c'est une action globale qui est
conduite pour assurer l'efficacité des
mesures de sécurité que nous prenons
pour l'ensemble de nos établissements
pénitentiaires merci monsieur bonhomme
pour 25 secondes
merci madame la ministre de votre
réponse j'en prends acte et je vous
donne est également de vos intentions
simplement quand pour regretter la
faible réactivité de google par rapport
à votre à vos injonctions parce que
malheureusement le mal est fait on peut
considérer que les captures d'écran eu
lieu et que si des choses peuvent se
préparer en utilisant ces données ces
données photographiques en espèces c'est
malheureusement le mal sera ne sera
difficile à réparer pour l'avenir gb
noter que vous souhaitiez faire évoluer
le cadre juridique qui encadre les
prises de vue aériennes jour que c'est
nécessaire et qu'on ne peut pas rester
en l'état par rapport à une situation
qui comme kick m insécure pour notre
pour notre sécurité pour les maisons
d'arrêt